hey 42 here there's something about the
experimental nature of science that
attracts the crazies you just won't
believe what despicable weird and
downright evil things these pioneers of
the bazaar have done
Sergey s bryukhonenko
was a soviet scientist and head of the
research institute of experimental
surgery during the Stalin era now that's
a recipe for a mad scientist if ever I
heard one
Sergey was the inventor of the first
artificial heart machine which he called
the auto ejected its main purpose was to
sustain life through artificial means it
was used to help perform the first
Soviet open-heart surgery seems to be
going pretty well so far doesn't it well
this is the bit where it goes weird
Sergei was obsessed with mutilating
animals then seeing how long he could
keep their dismembered heads alive his
laboratory was filled with dead mostly
headless dogs I told you it gets weird
Sergei is most infamous experiment was
documented on video and it involved
decapitating a dog which he then placed
on a table
Sergei then managed to bring the head
back to life using his homemade
life-support machine the severed dog's
head was fully responsive and it even
accepted a treat from the staff the
original recording of the experiment can
be found on the Internet but I should
warn you it's not for the faint-hearted
during World War two thousands of human
experiments were carried out by Nazi
scientists under Hitler's instruction
the goal of these experiments was to
discover new ways to a German military
personnel whom had been injured during
combat and also to discover radical new
medical treatment to advance Hitler's
ideology the leader of these experiments
was dr. Josef Mengele who earned himself
the nickname the angel of death for the
atrocities he carried out when new
inmates arrived at Auschwitz Mengele
would select which were to be gassed and
which would be taken to the laboratory
to conduct his inhumane experiments
Joseph Mengele was obsessed by twins he
would often attempt to stitch two flesh
blood vessels and organs of twins
together in an attempt to create Siamese
twins
but his subjects often contracted
gangrene and died after a couple of days
of unimaginable pain
Joseph performed experiments such as
putting victims into pressure chambers
castration freezing subjects to death
removal of organs and limbs and even
performing sex change operations most of
the victims were murdered following the
experiment if they didn't straight-up
die from the experiment that is during
the second sino-japanese war and World
War two the Imperial Japanese army set
up a covert biological and chemical
research and development base called
unit 731 they told the locals it was a
water treatment plant but that guys must
have fallen apart pretty quickly once
the locals realized that the screams of
tortured humans sounds remarkably
different than running water
microbiologist and medical officer Shiro
Ishii was the director of unit 731 he
committed numerous atrocities at the
unit 731 in the name of science
including vivisection on living people
without anesthetic including pregnant
women dismembering people's limbs then
reattaching them to other parts of their
bodies injecting subjects with deadly
diseases to study the effects and even
used people as live tests targets for
grenades and flamethrowers however after
the war ended she Oishi never spent any
time in jail for his atrocities because
he was granted immunity by the US
government some believe this is because
the u.s. made a pact with Japan during
the war to help cover up unit 731 in
exchange for medical knowledge of their
finding at number four is Sidney
Gottlieb but he had possibly the coolest
alias of all the evil scientists his
colleagues refer to him as dr. feelgood
he was an American military psychiatrist
with a PhD in chemistry during the Cold
War the CIA hired him to help develop
biological weapons and poisons to
views against the Russians but
Gottlieb's only answer to taking out
America's enemies was to poison them all
godly propose the idea of killing Fidel
Castro with Eva a poisoned cigar a
poisoned fountain pen or a poisoned
wetsuit who whichever was easiest it
turns out none was the answer since he's
still alive Gottlieb's offer
unsuccessful poisoning attempts included
an Iraqi general and the Prime Minister
of the Democratic Republic of the Congo
but that's just a tip of sidney gottlieb
weird iceberg he was also the head of
the MK ULTRA project which studied the
possibility of using LSD to mind-control
one's enemies they were interested if
the psychedelic drug could be used to
break a person's mind for the purpose of
interrogation
so Gottlieb and his colleagues spent a
large portion of their time getting high
on acid but they soon realized they
would need test subjects overdone
themselves however instead of inviting
willing subjects to get high on LSD
Gottlieb instead traveled around America
slipping LSD into people's drinks and
observing the effects he mainly targeted
prostitutes and drug addicts next up is
American psychologist Harry Harlow he
had the nickname of monkey torturer you
just know that this guy qualifies for
this video with a name like that he was
obsessed with finding out what is love
and for some unknown reason he decided
the best way to do that was by torturing
baby monkeys yes that's right baby
monkeys to achieve his goal holo
invented a range of monkey torturing
devices one of his most infamous he
lovingly referred to as the rape rack
hallo would use his rape rack device to
force monkeys to mate he also had a
device he called the Iron Maiden
but perhaps his most controversial
experiment was called the pit of despair
holla would place a baby monkey in a
small isolated chamber for up to a year
without any contact with another living
creature as a result the monkeys all
became psychotic
never recovered thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2